bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches
l'émission qui déconstruit pour vous les
mythes les plus tenaces
bonjour aujourd'hui nous allons vous
parler du pétrole
bonjour estelle bonjour olivier bonjour
à tous et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de ses caches quel est le rôle du
pétrole dans l'économie et la
géopolitique comment influence-t-il
notre monde tout lé pétrole se valent
t-il ce sont les questions qui vont nous
occuper aujourd'hui olivier justement
aujourd'hui la place du pétrole quand
est ce qu'il en est ce qu'il influence
toujours autant lé décision
oui puisque c'est la source d'énergie
principale donc alors vous en avez
d'autres mais c'est c'est une source
d'énergie qui est épuisable
ces consommables et donc c'est épuisable
comme le charbon peut l'être ex terrasse
donc ce ne sont pas des énergies
renouvelables
donc il faut se poser des questions sur
combien de pétrole va t'on encore de
combien de pétrole va t'on encore
disposés et surtout à quel prix parce
qu'un problème finalement
[Musique]
vous avez une histoire de quantité mais
vous avez surtout une histoire de
quantité par rapport à un prix vous
pouvez ne plus avoir de pétrole à 40
dollars le baril à extraire mais en
avoir encore à deux sens sauf qu'à 200
si vous voulez sur les économie actuelle
qui ont déjà très très peu de croissance
ça va être compliqué pour les années à
venir alors olivier justement vous
parliez en début d'émission est des
états unis le pays de l'oncle sam
extrait de plus en plus de pétrole de
schiste vont ils pour autant à gagner
leur indépendance énergétique éléments
de réponse avec le tiroir cash
d'entonner cesse avec plus de 12
millions de baril de pétrole extrait par
jour dont 7 millions de pétrole de
schiste les etats unis se taillent la
part du lion dans la production de
l'énergie fossile
à tel point que selon lagence mondial de
l'énergie dans la période 2010 9 2024
ils représenteront à eux seuls 70% de la
croissance de la production mondiale
leur permettant de passer devant la
russie d'ici 2023 et de ce cas c'est pas
très loin derrière le premier producteur
d'or noir
l'arabie saoudite alors les états unis
pourront-ils célébrer leur indépendance
énergétique booster leur et que 2000
avec leur pétrole de schiste et bien
tout n'est pas si simple
le pétrole de schiste est beaucoup moins
lourd que les pétroles plus
conventionnels comme celui par exemple
provenant du venezuela
et malheureusement pour les américains
leur raffinerie ne sont pas du tout
adaptés à traiter ce type de pétrole
très léger donc mais plutôt à
transformer du brut lourd depuis le
lancement de l'extraction massive de
schiste les raffineries n'ont pas encore
pu s'adapter correctement vu les énormes
investissements que cela demande
exxon première compagnie pétrolière
privée au monde a par exemple mis 9
milliards sur la table dans l'urgence et
pour le moment pour traiter ce fameux
pétrole léger
ils doivent le mélanger avec du plus
lourd qui vient d'autres pays
une situation qui pourrait malgré tout à
terme se régler et permettre aux états
unis de se passer de leurs douars les
autres l'avenir le dira mais en
attendant la courbe des importations de
pétrole aux états unis est en forte
chute
concept de la production ne fait
qu'augmenter depuis 2010 alors olivier
on vient de le voir les armes irakiennes
et américaines ne sont pas vraiment
adaptés pour traiter le pétrole de
schiste il songé dans l'un portait pour
le mélanger avec et pour autant on voit
que les importations diminuent comment
est ce qu'on explique cette équation
vous aurez ponctuellement des des
différences c'est à dire que vu que ça
ralentit le commerce mondial ralentit vu
que le commerce aux etats-unis aussi
ralenti et à voir les les données de
fret
il est assez assez probable que les la
consommation de pétrole elle aussi
ralentisse mais ces histoires de deux
raffineries et de raffineries qui sont
conçus pour un certain certaines
catégories de pétrole c'est pas rien
c'est à dire que si vous voulez qu'une
que cette raffinerie marche avec le
pétrole de schiste
vous allez vous retrouver avec des
investissements qui vont se chiffrer en
centaines de milliards pas aux milliards
donc si vous voulez c'est quelque chose
qui est je dirais presque irréversible
on n'est pas on n'est pas du tout quand
on parle de pétrole on n'est pas du tout
sûr d'aidé
des mouvements qui peuvent se faire
comme vous réguler le flux dans votre
baignoire c'est pas un robinet qu'on
ferme quand on dit ah bah oui mais toute
façon le l'opep va diminuer sa
production
ça se fait pas comme ça quand vous avez
un puits qui est lancée aux etats-unis
la production et lancer vous allez pas
l'arrêter vous n'avez pas arrêté depuis
pire prendre quelques jours plus tard
parce que le pétrole le prix du pétrole
a monté ça se fait pas comme ça
donc vous avez une production qui est ce
qu'elle est quand il lance un puits en
production ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que ces puits là les putschistes sont
des puits qui donne le maximum
les premiers mois après c'est une chute
continuelle
au bout de trois ans il donne plus rien
donc vous avez le fait qu'il faut sans
cesse forêt un peu plus des trous
partout et bientôt vous allez voir que
c'est pas du pétrole que les états unis
vont importer c'est de l'eau parce
qu'ils sont en train de pourrir tout
leur toutes leurs
tous leurs puis dodo et toutes leurs
réserves d'eau donc attention à ça on va
parler de ça avec notre invité justement
place à la deuxième partie de cette
émission cette semaine nous recevons
jean laherrère président de l'aspo
france l'association pour l'étude des
pic pétrolier et gazier
bonjour jean laherrère merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
bienvenue merci de m'avoir invité alors
vous allez nous montrer il n'y a pas en
pétrole mais plusieurs pétrole il ya
autant de pétrole qui a deux champs de
pétrole dans le monde et ghana trente
mille donc chacun est différent et donc
voyez par exemple ça c'est un pétrole
indonésien ça c'est un pétrole français
bassin de paris ça c'est un pétrole
américain heath texas qui a été
découvert en 1930 qui produit toujours
et ça par contre c'est du pétrole
synthétique et à partir de das d'envoyer
à ce moment là bas on fait quelque chose
qui est qui est très pure qui on dirait
d'eau donc les pétrole se caractérise
par la densité et le loto de souffleur
justement là ils n'ont pas tous la même
qualité
non non ils n'ont pas tous et donc un
pétrole qui est léger sera donc plus à
l'heure
intéressant que quand mettre l'eau en
reste comme disait olivier tout à
l'heure ça dépend de la raffinerie et
des raffineries qui sont équipés pour de
lourds alors que l'autre sens et qui
pèse sur le budget
alors justement monsieur vous avez
rapporté un graphique avec voit très
bien
d'un côté il ya le taux de soufre sexe à
traiter la densité est grave plus le
pétrole a dû souffre mais pas plus plus
il est mauvais et plus
plus il est léger plus il est
intéressant mais je voulais vous dire
que là l'énergie d'un pétrole dépendent
surtout de sa densité c'est exactement
le même cas pour les carburants un
diesel est beaucoup plus énergique et
13% au litre plus énergétique que
l'essence parce qu'il est plus lourd si
on vendait le le péno diesel au litre ça
ferait ça serait bien ce serait
engendrée de l'énergie au point haut
pour arriver au poids et toutes visent
le vendant au litre on donne un avantage
considérable considérable des ailes qui
se chiffrent qui se chiffre à 15
milliards à peu près eux c'est ça oui
donc si vous voulez des il faudrait que
le diesel soit vendu 13 % préfèrent le
plus en plus chers comme il est vendu
plus cher en angleterre en suisse aux
états unis et c'est aux niches fiscales
qui est une niche fiscale représentait
16 milliards il ya quelques années
encore j'ai refermé les calculs
il ya deux jours c'était 10 milliards en
2019 et cumulé ça fait plus de 500
milliards d'euros
quels sont les pays qui produisent du
bon pétrole et quels sont les projets du
président mauvais pétrole tout dépend de
la raffinerie les raffineries
américaines et sont habitués aux lourds
elles sont conçues pour le lourd donc
elle va acheter de l'eau d'autres
d'autres son compte de vos pôles et j'ai
donc comment ils produisent des mauvais
pétrole de pétrole de pétrole tout
dépend tout dépend de prix le mauvais
pétrole il est vendu à pas cher le tente
on dit de vous lisez votre journal
on nous dit le pétrole c'est mettons 60
dollars d'aidé barils 1 mais en
définitive le canadien qui est très
lourd et qui souffrait lui il est vendu
20 30 et d'autres peut être vendu 70 80
quand il est bon mais tout dépend de la
raffinerie en feu grillé ce qu'il a
besoin et c'est ce que ce que les gens
comprennent pas c'est que justement une
raffinerie ça ça se modifie pas c'est
pas une histoire de robin et c'est pas
donc ça ne se modifie pas le mix qu'on
emploie dans une rue dans une raffinerie
ne se modifie pas juste comme ça par
l'opération du saint-esprit
ça nécessite des investissements majeurs
et des investissements majeurs qui se
chiffrent en centaines de milliards donc
vous ne pouvez pas comme ça du jour au
lendemain dire ah bah on va utiliser
plus qu'un pétrole ça n'existe pas c'est
bien pour ça que les états unis continue
à importer du pétrole d'autres régions
pétrole de mer du nord pétrole d'arabie
saoudite échos et compagnie en plus ça
il ne faudrait cet investissement si
savait que ce pétrole de schiste qui
n'est pas du taux de schiste d'ailleurs
c'est federer et revoir compact durerait
20 ans parce que si vous voulez là ils
amortissent mais qu'on m'entend glee
savent tous que ça va décliner dans
quelques années
donc ils ne font pas les investissements
c'est qu'on ne fait pas les
investissements pour les gazoducs parce
qu'on sait que c'est éphémère le pétrole
et le gaz de schiste donc ça ça c'est
important parce qu'aujourd'hui il ya une
idée commune qui est de 10
grâce au pétrole de schiste les
américains vont prendre le lead sur le
sur les exportations et roll or c'est
faux c'est à dire qu'il faut bien
comprendre que tous les champs
pétroliers américains aujourd'hui les
champs de schiste pétroliers américains
aujourd'hui dans quelques donc quelques
temps vont s'arrêter de produire parce
que le la courbe de production c c'est
une exponentielle pendant les premiers
mois
et puis après ça ça ne fait que se
casser la figure c'est à dire que vous
êtes obligés de percer des trous de plus
en plus vous êtes obligés d'injecter des
produits chimiques de plus en plus et
c'est pour ça que je vous disais et
nappes phréatiques vont en faire les
frais et bientôt et nous importerons de
l'eau car justement on va parler des
coûts d'extraction a qui ne sont pas les
mêmes partout on va le voir avec ce
graphique le pétrole le moins cher à
extraire et celui du moyen-orient et 27
dollar par baril par baril 50 pour la
russie et ça monte à 75 pour l'arctique
qu'est ce qui explique ces différences
de coûts d'extraction oui mais ça c'est
des chiffres qui sont sortis parce que
vous voulez toutes les données
pétrolières sont confidentielles et tous
les chiffres tous les chiffres que vous
voyez qui sont publiés par les
gouvernements ses positions ça veut dire
que le pétrole du moyen-orient ne coûte
en réalité pas 27
ça dépend de quel de chaque sac chaque
chant est différent alors bien sûr si
vous calculez le prix de revient d'un
champ si vous tenez compte simplement de
ce qu'a coûté l'installation mais il
faut que tenir compte de tout l'arrivée
c'est à dire qu'il faut tenir compte de
toutes les explorations qui s'est passé
après je veux dire il faut tenir compte
des frais de de gestion de management
la plupart des gens qui vous saute sur
un chiffre c'est qu'il a choisi ce qui
lui plaît moi je peux vous sortir
n'importe quel chiffre si vous voulez
qu'ils soient bas ou la fourchette est
énorme et chaque sac de quelqu'un qui
vous donne un chiffre et non une
fourchette ça veut dire qui ment par
omission
donc mon donc l'ailé
les coûts des tractions bien sûr il ya
des gisements qui sont à très très
branché b le tout c'est qu'il faut
raisonner un champ ses 50 ans et donc si
vous voulez raisonner sur ses 50 ans ou
même sentons par exemple if they xal
four ou d'autres il faut actualiser les
coûts et les revenus
quel taux d'années d'inde
d'actualisation à menton 1 dont une
femme et ses fils s'est défini autrefois
en prenait 15 % mais si on va marquer à
une courte pause on revient dans un
instant bienvenue dans ces caches si
vous nous rejoignez on parle du pétrole
avec jean laherrère président de l'aspo
france ou sur la rentabilité on le voit
aussi sur le graphique le baril de
schiste américain coûte selon lui 65
dollars à extraire par larry et est-ce
qu'il est rentable ce système à l'heure
actuelle le pétrole de schiste a été
fait par a été mis en place par des
petits promoteurs un séjour michels a
commencé avec le gars a su apprécier et
le pétrole mais si vous voulez par
exemple le grand promoteur de gacé
chesapeake chesapeake a été un moment le
premier producteur de gaz aux etats-unis
et le ch et ça pique a toujours s'est
endettée et de son revenu et est très
inférieure à ses dépenses mais tous ces
promos de petits promoteurs y gagne sur
la bourse donc un ighil sont tous payés
en stock options donc la compagnie est
en négatif
la plupart ya à peu près 200 compagnies
pétrolières qui sont mis en faillite
mais tous les patrons sont partis avec
des avec des lions gagnent esclaves boxe
don qui gagne sur la bourse
si le pétrole de schiste c'est dû
simplement que le taux de l'emprunt à
l'heure actuelle est très bas parce
qu'un truc de donald e
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est quand on
parle de coûts d'extraction c'est pas le
coût d'extraction c'est le financement
d'ailleurs l'achat du terrain auprès des
fermiers texan qui vaut le terrain c'est
l'achat de la galaure en fait de la
concession et c'est tout ce qu'il ya
autour c'est à dire les investissements
les le coût de l'emprunt que vous faites
auprès de la banque etc etc
parce que on parle toujours des taux à
zéro mais quand un pétrolier un petit
pétrolier va voir sa banque pour creuser
un trou là les taux ils sont pas 0 ils
sont ils sont bien plus élevés que ça et
donc que si on continue avec un pétrole
qui est durablement en dessous du prix
de revient
vous allez avoir tout un tas de petites
sociétés qui vont sauter et qui
continuent d'ailleurs il y en a
actuellement qui vont sauter les grosses
balles vont compenser un peu pendant
pendant quelques temps mais les petites
elles vont sauter et qui vont mettre en
difficulté les banques qui leur ont
prêté mais ça aujourd'hui de personne ne
s'en occupe mais c'est vrai que depuis
ce qui est intéressant aussi c'est que
depuis 2008 tout de même tout l'argent
qui a été mis à bénéficier aussi à
l'essor du du pétrole de schiste
et quand vous voyez pétrole de schiste
est d'ailleurs tout ce qu'il ya autour
c'est à dire il y avait des villes
entières qui ce qui se monte avec le
transport avec la vie des bébés des gens
qui travaillaient là bas et donc tout ça
a mené non seulement des emplois mais
aussi de l'activité etc
or ça si on a ce pétrole qui reste sur
la zone des 50 dollars voire moins dans
l'est sur sur eux sur un an
vous allez avoir des difficultés
sérieuses sur tous ce micro system qui
est le le système du pétrole de schiste
et donc on va avoir pas ce que je vous
dis on n'est pas quand vous avez payé
pour une concession vous fait le trou
derrière parce que sinon si vous le
faites pas pendant un an
vous ne pouvez plus faire vous êtes
obligés de payer du dédit donc c'est pas
si facile à réguler que ça et je pense
qu'on va avoir des difficultés si on a
un pétrole qui reste sur ces prix là est
ce qu'on peut imaginer qu'à terme avec
le pétrole de schiste les américains
soient énergétiquement indépendant banon
la ferai des prévisions
c'est un 2040 et ils seront ils sont de
nouveau ils sont en train de frôler
indépendance mais pour le pour le gars
cynisme mais pour le pétrole non et arf
il a frôlé il a frôlé mais ce qu'il ya
c'est que de les prévisions officielles
de l'agencé internationale de l'énergie
ou d'excès mobilisés en 2040 qu'ils
seront exportateurs et pour alimenter
l'europe l'europe et c'est exactement
pour les même chose pour le gaz quand
contre un vent de l'est merkel sur le
north stream candidat il faut pas
prendre le gaz du poutine c'est parce
qu'il compte que 1 compte vendre du gaz
liquéfié en 2040 à l'europe mais y en
aura pas pour moi si nous voulons des
1040 tout ce qui met plus moi je fais du
moins bon mais c'est à dire qu'il est de
nouveau ils vont apporter plusieurs
millions d'euros par jour il prépare du
thé exportés ont pas danon en dessous du
moment l'unil en 2040
à l'heure actuelle ils envoient un peu
de gaz liquéfié du gaz de schiste mais
ça va se terminer pour moi pour moi mes
prévisions c'est que le pétrole de
schiste parce que quand on voit les
courbes de d'origan fin d'appareils de
forage qui décroît et cetera le déplacer
pour cette année et je peux voir et si
le déclin est aussi pour moi qui voulais
je suis fasciné par la symétrie des
cobras un tout ce qui monte on descend
avec la même somme et riffs donc le
pétrole de schiste est montée comme ça
mais ça va redescendre comme ça et ça
veut peut redescendre moi je fais un
pari mais je vais sans doute le perdre
c'est que si le pétrole de chine
liste des cent cette année suffisamment
pour que ça soit notable en moins
novembre trump ne sera pas est-ce que
mal gré mal gré la transition écologique
malgré l'image du pétrole mais pas
vraiment ban
oui pour autant ça reste une
préocupation reste une préoccupation
majeure
si vous voulez quand vous regardez les
prévisions bon j'ai filé qui sont
officielles pour bus qui les font
jusqu'en 2040 en 2040 le renouvelable
il prévoit un déclin du pétrole mais une
le renouvelable n'arrivera à compenser
que si on met un solaire si on le
multiplie par part par sens il faut il
faut actuellement 1 toutes les
prévisions de dire que on va compter sur
une ouvrables pour moi c'est celle c'est
vraiment s'est développée mais vous
savez on vous ment moment là la
naissance en vous parlant du père noël
et à votre mort en reproduisant la vie
éternelle pour moi tout ça pour vous
pour vous une bonne chute
ça va être
il ya beaucoup de il ya beaucoup de
prévisions qui sont en fait des
prévisions politique c'est à dire on
vous a parlé aussi du venezuela un
moment qu'ils ont que c'était des
réserves avec ses mannequins
je maintiens c'est le seul olympien
c'est le plus grand jeu réservé mais si
vous voulez un camp total a pris un
permis dans les allées les sables valeur
le pétrole lourd de l'orénoque c'était
en 84 98 tout le pétrole était à 10 $ en
ce moment on a écrit à la fin du pétrole
bon marché mais calling un peu et on lui
disait mais commencé pour vous justifier
de produire de gasser de leurs de
l'orénoque avec les dollars du baril
mais 10 juin que nous avons un contrat
de 35 ans et à ce moment là un puits
dans il fallait une semaine pour forêt
avec des pompes incombe activité un
progressive ont produit des mille barils
par jour et on avait un permis ou on
pouvait forêt pendant pendant 30 ans
autant depuis qu'on voulait donc le
pétrole venait julia il est pas cher
seulement il faut le transporter y est
lourd et et où total s'est complètement
planté c'est que le pétrole à monter
mais dès qu'il a montée ils ont été
nationalisées donc en disant que l'alors
leur projet était bien oui sauf s'il
fallait pas se faire de nationalité par
chavez on a beaucoup parlé
bon on en avait parlé alors après il ya
eu des bd des prévisions de de stocks
qui ont enflé aussi vite que la crise
augmente et au venezuela donc moi je
mettrais quand même des quelques
quelques bémols là dessus
les réserves prouvées ces politiques
d'abord c'est bolt y prouver c'est vous
avez deux réserves prouvées ce pour la
sec la sec un stock
sécurité la commission aux états unis
toute compagnie qui est sur la liste sur
la bourse américaine dont total tous les
majors sont obligés d'avoir les règles
de la sec
les règles de la sec il faut protéger le
banquier et l'actionnaire donc c'est la
vézère minimum aucun si on fait faillite
de façon à ce qu'ils soient sûrs de
récupérer la remise mais vous n'avez pas
le droit d'ajouter statistiquement des
réserves minimum donc le canton ajouté
réserves prouvées ses skis en intérim en
faut mais est-ce que les est ce que les
déserts et les réserves probables
enfin moyenne merci beaucoup à jean
laherrère d'avoir été un parmi nous pour
cette émission je rappelle que vous êtes
président de l'aspo france l'association
pour l'étude des pic pétrolier et gazier
c'est l'heure du chiffre de la semaine
olivier le chômage a baissé de 3 3% en
2010 neuf au total il y a un peu plus de
3 5 millions de demandeurs d'emploi sans
aucune activité sur l'ensemble du
territoire comment peut-on expliquer
cette baisse olivier cela m'est déjà
capable baisse en fait c'est un chiffre
là aussi politique
donc on vous annonce une forte baisse du
chômage alors qu'elle n'a pas eu lieu
c'est à dire que comme d'habitude on
vous met qu'une catégorie
et puis on ne vous dit pas
qu' il ya des radiations par centaines
de milliers que vous avez des stages de
formation qui s'arrêteront le 5 janvier
et qui font que cette ce chiffre est
totalement artificielle en bon on a
l'habitude un canter quand on est
incompétent on truquer le thermomètre
mais parmi les demandeurs d'emploi si
vous n'avez pas les gens qui sortent qui
sortent définitivement du des
statistiques donc vous truquez le
chiffre comme ça enfin je veux dire on a
refait les calculs la baisse elle est
loin des 3 3% très très loin et donc
mais ça a toujours été tout pendant
toute l'année on l'a on l'a dit est
évidemment le l'addition de tous les
méfaits que le chômage ne baisse pas
alors le chômage ne baisse pas c'est un
chiffre qui est un chiffre politique
mais si vous avez la même chose je vous
rassure dans tous les pays ça ne savait
pas uniquement la regarde pas en chine
s'est elle a enregistré des créations
d'emplois se chiffrent essor il sort pas
que vous ayez des créations d'emplois
est une chose
après que vous ayez des créations
d'emplois il faut pas oublier celle qui
s'arrête enfin les emplois qui sont
les gens qui sont au chômage et puis
secundo on ne parle jamais non plus de
la qualité des emplois créés si vous
voulez si vous avez des gens qui se
mettent en auto entrepreneur et qui
ferment quelques mois plus tard parce
qu'ils n'en peuvent plus et qu'il
n'arrive pas à faire de l'argent des
gens qui sont engagés non plus ras durée
indéterminée mais à durée déterminée et
c'est tout ça c'est des c'est des choses
qu'on ne compte jamais parce que comme
vous avez en plus c'était auto
entrepreneurs qu'est ce qui se passe
quand vous arrêtez votre votre
entreprise
généralement vous n'êtes pas assurés
contre le chômage donc vous ne rentrez
pas dans les statistiques donc à tout ça
c'est des choses à prendre en compte que
ne prennent pas en compte - 3 3 qui est
juste ridicule c'est de la fausse pub
merci beaucoup olivier c'est la fin de
cette émission merci de l'avoir suivie
pour voir ou revoir nos précédents
numéros
rendez vous sur notre site internet à
l'adresse rt france point être tv vous
pouvez aussi réagir à cette émission sur
les réseaux sociaux avec le hashtag rt
cash olivier klein dernier mot et bien
comme disait jean laherrère tous les
chiffres sont des chiffres politique
donc faux